well as states now are beginning to roll
back at least some coronavirus
traditions a lot of parents are
surprised to learn that the cdc's
guidelines for summer camps
is going to be very strict this year it
includes masks
indoors and outdoors as well as social
distancing for all the kids
but dr anthony fauci says there could be
some
changes listen i wouldn't call them
excessive the cdc
makes decisions based on science they
will continually re-evaluate that
you're right it looks a bit strict a bit
stringent
dr mark siegel joins us now he is a fox
news contributor dr siegel let's pull
up some of the guidelines so we can get
on the same page here quickly
masks at all times unless eating or
swimming
no close contact sports shareable
objects
got to be limited campers have to stay
three or else
six feet apart they got to maintain that
distance while eating
napping or riding the bus and two layers
of masks
when social distancing is impossible dr
siegel the first question here is
what data is behind these guidelines
well this this is very antiquated it's
it's out of date
and it's not based on current science
and first of all julian i'm worried that
with these guidelines i always say
well the guidelines are just guidelines
but the problem is that if these
guidelines remain in place
then there's potential legal problems if
camps don't follow them right
well first of all we know from the
course of the pandemic that covet 19 is
that the cov2 virus is not spreading on
surfaces very often very unusual
so why can't they shift so no one acts
like a second issue
right i mean you know every time i go
into a store people are still pumping me
with hand sanitizer doing i mean i want
to tell them
the jig's up well
i don't mind the hand sanitizer because
again you could you could touch
something and get it on your face or
you know i'm okay with the hand washing
but the surfaces are not where it's
transmitted
and it's clearly a respiratory virus
that's transmitted in the air
and here's the other part of the science
multiple studies now have shown
that it is not transmitted outdoors
except rarely a study in ireland
showed less than 100 cases was outdoors
japan here in the united states the cdc
has all of this data showing
it's not spreading outdoors now so you
want to put a mask on a two-year-old
when it's not spreading outdoors
when less than 300 young children have
actually died of covet over the course
of the entire pandemic
flu has a very similar number than that
what is the
what is the public health cost of trying
to do this
of trying to superimpose masks on kids
who are doing sports outside i was very
happy to see
that you don't have to wear a mask when
you're swimming because there's 700
drownings every year among kids imagine
if we forced kids to wear masks when
swimming
so take a listen i'm laughing because
some of this stuff is so obviously
counterintuitive and dangerous
that it's hard to have any other
response okay listen to the cdc director
rachelle well let's go and get your
reaction on the other side
what we're really trying to avoid in
this camp guidance is what we saw in
outbreaks and camps last summer so if
you have five
ten-year-olds who are on a soccer field
all in front of the same soccer ball
we're trying to make sure that they're
not
a lot of heavy breathing around a
singular soccer ball with five kids
around it at the same time
all right dr siegel here's the thing
about what she just said
this summer ain't last summer we're
doing pretty well
infections nationwide down 16 percent
over the last week only
four states saw a uptick in cases 26
saw a major fall
yeah and and that's really correct
julian and i'm glad you brought that up
and california has a
has a test positivity rate of less than
one percent
new york closing down on one percent
meaning one out of a hundred people who
think they have covet
are actually the only ones that have it
so we're going way down
and in addition to that i want to add
you could test
kids i respect dr wolinski a lot but
she's leaving out that we now have rapid
testing
home testing you could do surveillance
testing and keep everything open
you can't play sports with masks on that
just doesn't work
what about respiratory risks of taking a
four-year-old and having them
run full tilt with a mask on i bet
there's more of a public health risk
doing that
than having the masks off kids are not
spreading this kids are very unlikely to
spread it
we've known that over the last few
months counselors can get vaccinated
great sounds like a perfect solution you
always have a reasonable answer for us
dr siegel thanks so much
thanks jillian thanks for having me